Welcome back to another episode of Paragliding Atlas Podcast.
I'm your host, Aninda Singh, and joining us today is none other
than the man himself, Nick Nenes.
Nick, what an absolute pleasure to have you on the show, man.
Thank you so much for coming. Thank you, it's been a while
since I've been on a Perry clothing podcast but.
Yeah, Nick, you know, I have been wanting to get you on the
show since I started the show. And I've been like, you know,
I've been aware. I've been admiring your
lifestyle, the way you fly and everything.
But most importantly, something that has made me very curious
and intrigued about you is, is that your Instagram handle or
YouTube handle? I don't know.
It's got a very cool name. It says share my joys.
God damn, dude. What's the story behind that
name? So I stole it.
It was a book that I read from a mountaineering God that I never
met, but like someone, I don't know, maybe in the 50s or
sometimes before I was born. And, and that was the title of
the book. So I just stole it.
But yeah, they were just talking about all their their adventures
in in the mountains and that kind of thing in in New Zealand
as well. Yeah.
Like for for the perspective of our listeners, you know, the the
show is 2 years old and I think you you're the most active years
of you in in paragliding were a little bit earlier than that.
So for the pilots who have just practised the out of flight not
that long ago, a little introduction about you if you
can. Yeah, so I learnt to fly in 2007
and I learnt in the southeast corner of Queensland, like the
eastern part of Australia. And the first thing I did was
like, I read about how light the wings were on the Internet and I
thought you could take these into the mountains and, and fly
by yourself. And then I talked to the
instructor in Kanungra where I learnt and I said, can can you
really like, what's the story? And he said, first you've got to
learn how to fly. I learnt in May 2007 and by the
end of the year I was doing my first flights in New Zealand,
literally jumping over the fence at the back of Mum's place and
knocking up the hill. That's such a cool training
ground, I would say, because the excitement and the rush that you
have as a new beginner pilot, like somebody who has just got
in the sport is like you can't get your you can't get enough of
it right. So if you have something that I
set up like that in your backyard, I think that must have
contributed to your better initial progression
comparatively to others. Yeah, so, so for me, the the
main reason I got into flying was not really from aviation
side or a love of flight or just wanting to fly no matter what or
whatever. It was more that I just wanted
to explore places and that was a tool to do it.
But it was it was really hot. I can fly.
That was really interesting to me.
And since then when I started learning flying, I realized that
you can actually take off and go up as well.
And, and you can not just climb up something and fly down South.
Yeah. Then then I learned a lot more
about the air itself and. And that was also an interesting
part of it. But the start of it was just
exploring country that I already knew.
Like I'd spend a lot of time looking at maps.
I'd done a lot of trips just on foot, like we call it tramping
in New Zealand, visiting a lot of these places.
And there was one time I always tell a story where I, I climbed
up from the valley and I got almost up to this Alpine lake,
but the Bush got really thick. And it was so thick that I had
to take off my pack and drag it after me and to go 30 meters.
That was, you know, very steep. But it was very short distance,
like 100 feet, Took me 30 meters, took me 30 minutes.
So when you're used to that kind of travel time in your
mountains, depending on what it's like, it's nice to be able
to think that you can just fly straight over the top.
So yeah, I spent a lot of time looking at maps and just
dreaming about trips I could do. Like, I would say that for me,
paragliding had three parts to it.
One was thinking about flights you could do, and another one
was doing the flights, and the other one was going back and
thinking about what you've done. And that's what I've spent a lot
of time video editing. And that was an enjoyable part
of it. Sometimes you feel like, oh, how
am I going to get through all this footage?
But usually when you get started it's quite fun reviewing what
you you did and seeing if if the flight was actually like you
thought it was when you landed, if it was maybe different to how
you remembered. A a quick thought comes from my
mind because you mentioned that, you know, the anxiety that comes
with all the footage that we capture because it's it's so
huge and editing is such a skill that yeah, you need to put in a
lot of work towards it. Like sometimes I, I think I've
told this on the show before that editing a 62nd trailer for
this show takes almost like 6-7 hours.
So it, it takes a huge chunk out of your name.
I was just kind of wondering like only if the hardware
manufacturers could make, what do you say the software as well.
So user friendly that because right now everybody is able to
operate Gopro's because they're so easy to operate, but almost
like 95% of them don't know what to do with the footage because
it's so damn hard to edit the footage.
And eventually like you buy the camera out of excitement because
it looks fancy. And all the adverts that you see
are very professionally edited. But I have seen almost 95% of
the pilots just letting their GoPro eat dust after like the
first couple of weeks or something because they don't
know what to do with it anymore afterwards.
So. I agree.
I've got two things to say about that.
One is that like the fact that I edited a lot of my footage gave
me feedback to not take as much footage and just to do short
clips. So when I made the video about
my accident, a lot of people said how come you didn't include
the accident and was like, well, I don't record all the time.
I just record, you know, it, one turn in a thermal or say a few
words when I'm on the glide somewhere, and just do it when
something interesting or different is happening.
I don't like record the whole thing because it would be too
much work to go through it all. Plus you've got to have the card
space and the battery and all that.
So you're having the feedback of having to edit means that I was
a lot more deliberate and succinct when I was making the
footage to make that part easier.
Because I, yeah, I was thinking about making really nice videos.
Like what? Like around the time of the
pandemic, I thought I'll get some decent cameras and I'll do
a decent job because a lot of the time I was making videos
just basically for my own memories.
But, you know, Ben Callard and and Ben Jordan, they make videos
which are really nice, but they spend an awful lot of time doing
it. Or at least.
Yeah. So there's a lot of, you know,
having different cameras and, and not being as fast on the
ground, like maybe missing a couple of flights because you
spent too much time trying to set the cameras up or whatever.
I don't know. So yeah, what was my second
point that yeah, I was basically doing it as a story and not as
a, you know, amazing experience for the user.
It's great if people get something out of watching the
videos, but it's it's more for me just to remember it.
And yeah, anyway, so I never got on to making those really good
videos because I had the accident after the pandemic but
before I got to get go back to New Zealand.
But it's leave all that hard work up to those other guys.
You know, I think you mentioned two people who have actually
invested. They're like, you know, a lot of
pilots, they invest their time, energy and effort into chasing
distance of getting better and flying.
But these are like 2 guys. I mean, I'm sure there are many
others, but these are two guys that stand out when it comes to
the amount of effort they invest in bringing you along their
adventures. In case any of the viewers are
wondering who we are talking about.
Yeah, just just look up for Benjamin in the index of this
show and you will find both of them have been on Paragliding
Atlas. So there are episodes with
Benjamin Jordan and Benjamin Kellett where they spill all the
secrets on how they bring this awesomeness to your screens.
But Nick, I was going to come to your accident eventually because
it is kind of, you know, how do I say a looming possibility that
kind of sticks around at any given point of time in life, in
instance, in paragliding life is what I meant.
After how many years of flying did that accident happen?
And how has flying looked like for you afterwards?
OK, so I learnt in 2007 and I had my accident 15 years after
that. I had actually been gliding
since the pandemic, so I'd started doing that as well.
But yeah, I had a lot of adventures in in 15 years.
So that's three and a bit years ago.
And yeah, after that I haven't really had an interest in
paragliding. I think it is a great activity
because I'm a paraplegic, so waist up is OK for a lot of
paraplegic people. Paragliding might be a great
activity, but it depends what you want to get out of it.
And for me, the main things that were special about paragliding
were the independence that you could do everything on your own
and that you could take off at land just about anywhere.
So that's not really applicable if you're paraplegic.
But if you just want to take off, fly a local site or fly
coastal, it can be great. But gliding since I before the
the year before the accident, I started gliding in a French club
that already has gliders that are set up for disabled people
because you use your feet for the rudders in a normal glider.
But there is a modified ones. Yeah, luckily.
Exactly. Sail playing gliders.
Yep. So I could fly with those guys
again after the accident at the same club, but evolved a lot
more paperwork and bureaucracy to get my medical and to get all
that drama going. It took a lot of effort.
So paragording is the other advantage of it is it's
relatively straightforward in terms of aviation regulations
and rules and stuff like that. Sometimes I was attracted
towards base because of how unregulated it is, because I
somehow feel that humans thrive evaluating risk best when they
don't have anybody to fall back on.
When they know that nobody's got their back.
It's like, yeah, the buck stops with me because you are the ones
who's going to reap the rewards and you are the ones who's going
to pay the price if you do something out of the spectrum.
Regulations are always a bit of a hit and miss in my head as
like yes, when it comes to masses, education is important
because otherwise you won't guide them correctly.
But when it comes to the niches, which is like selected few, I
think chasing excellence can only come when you are managing
the drive within you according to your own abilities.
Rather than having paperwork put some kind of a structure
definition around it which changes your perception of risk.
It's like risk perception as a stand alone person versus risk
perception being a part of the system.
Yeah. Commercial aviation, it's
probably justified that there is a lot of regulation if they've
got a lot of layers of catching mistakes so they don't turn into
accidents. Paragliding, the weight of the
aircraft is just a few kilos and your speed is one of the slowest
aircrafts. So yeah, it makes sense that you
don't regulate that as much. And gliding, I think it makes
sense that it's in between those two extremes.
Europe is quite highly regulated compared to other countries.
Yeah. The thing is the the gliding
clubs aren't really the ones helping you to get through it
all, but it's the association that's all over Europe.
So it combines all the different countries together and to get
anything changed as a real dramas.
It is what it is. In terms of gliding, I think
Australia is a lot more straightforward.
From what I hear, you can have an experimental category there
for the glottis, which makes things there's a lot more
flexibility. But New Zealand is probably
somewhere in between Australia and Europe.
OK, so regulating one example that comes to my mind which of a
flawed regulation is let's say the EN standard.
Time and again we have seen the whole crowd going about how
ineffective this is and how it gives you a false perception and
people are making decisions based on this standard, whereas
it is only supposed to educate you on very specific parameters
because they are the only ones we are able to measure in a
controlled environment. Any other parameter is not
measurable. So I feel like there's a pseudo
safety that comes in people's mind with a certain bit of
regulation. Even though a lot of
manufacturers and top test pilots say that certification is
not supposed to be taken as something to choose the wing.
But because that regulation exists and the audience below it
who is looking up to that regulation is like, let's say a
new pilot, he's going to go to his instructor and the
instructor is going to see how the industry standard is.
So even the instructor are saying that yes, it's AE and a
glider. That's why you should buy it.
That depends on how qualified the instructor is, how much his
experience is because at the level of teaching instructors,
the regulation is very different compared to the regulation
controlling how the wings are produced.
I feel that pseudo safety messes up with your risk management
because right now the student has OK.
My instructor has my 100% trust because he has been flying for a
while and instructor thinks that the EN certification has 100%
trust because it has been in place for a while.
But the bottom line is that the instructor is not even close to
answering the question that both the student and instructor are
seeking. So.
Yeah. But did he talk with Luke Hamont
about this? And he said you shouldn't look
at the EN rating and you should look at what the manufacturer
says about it because they're the ones pitching it to a
certain market. So yeah, that makes sense.
Yeah, it's interesting. But that's one thing that I was
thinking about before. This is like when you go on a
ride at a theme park, you're kind of like, well, it's safe.
Like, it's been tested, Someone's done it before.
But paragliding, it's not like that.
Like, you never can guarantee. I mean, you can't guarantee that
the theme park ride won't break, but it's different every single
time you fly. And accidents do happen quite a
lot. So I think it's definitely a
dangerous sport and some people like to tick boxes and say if I
tick all these boxes then I won't have an accident.
Like I found after my accident, I felt there was a psychological
thing that a lot of people want to know what you did wrong
because you must have done something wrong because
something bad happened and it must have been something that
you did. It's definitely more likely that
you'll have an accident if you do something wrong, but it's
also a dangerous sport. And sometimes things happen.
And I think there's a psychological thing that people
want to say. An accident will only happen to
me if I do something wrong. So as long as I don't do
anything wrong, I'm safe. I don't think that's true.
I think you're safer, but you're not safe.
So I think that's a psychological thing that people
say, oh, it won't happen to me. And when I had my accident, I
realized that I've had accidents where I've been fine in the
past. But yeah, this time I wake up in
hospital, I'm like, OK, it didn't work out.
But later I found out it's actually not as much my fault as
you would assume because it was really the rescue helicopter
that blew me down the hill. I still think paragliding is
dangerous. People die a lot from it.
But in my case, I feel like I managed the risks OK.
I just probably had a bit of bad luck, but I've also had a lot of
good luck, So there you go. OK.
Risk is it more or less as you mentioned life will happen as it
is. There are people because this is
what I want to talk a little bit about insurance as well.
I learnt in India where insurances were nothing when I
started, I had no clue about it. Maybe they were still in place,
but I was just not interested or felt the inclination towards
finding 1. And I was like, buddy, you are
going out and practicing something which is outside the
normal norms of the society. So just own up your
responsibility and deal with it like there's nothing, no rocket
science to it. Nobody's coming to save your
ass. You're out there by yourself.
Insurances became a big thing when I moved here to Europe.
It was like, yeah, you got to pay like €300 a month for this
and two more for this and like in the end of the whole package
goes up to 6700 and now you're freaking secure.
Now you can go in any thermal circle the hell out of it and
you know, go in the lease highs because there is somebody
looking out for you. Yet at the same time, your
accident and Tim Leonetti, both of these are like, I'm just
using these as an example. With all due respect to them,
these were in the thick of the things where insurances work at
a flick of a finger. These are the places where
legislations have been doing things right and the systems are
in place, yet the outcome was undesirable.
So risk mitigation versus risk perception, how does risk look
like for you when there is insurance and when there's no
insurance? Because I feel that if you fly
without a reserve, you're going to fly a lot more responsibly,
even though having a reserve is a lot more desirable.
In my case, the reserve parachute would let.
Me, I'm giving you an example of reserve because let's say if you
take reserve as an insurance like if something goes wrong
then reserve is going to save my ass.
But if you do not have a reserve, then you're shit scared
and you won't push the envelope that far where something could
go wrong. So same goes for insurance.
It's like if there is insurance, you can do whatever the hell you
want. There is somebody looking out
for you. But if there's no insurance, you
know you're out there by your own.
So you got to save your own ass. You won't go that far.
Yeah, yeah. So for me, there was 2 reasons
to get insurance. One is to tick the box.
So they let you compete in exhales because if you don't
have it, they won't let you do it.
And the other one is to help you pay for things if there's an
accident. In my case, the insurance isn't
any good for the accident. Financially.
I'm worse off because of that. Financially help.
They're not. They're not going to fix the
spinal injuries. Yeah, you can get insurance to
help you financially, but your life is not going to be much
different. Yeah, the financial thing is
major, but it wasn't the main thing with the accident.
I would like to re clarify what I meant is risk mitigation when
it comes to having a safety net. That is what I meant.
Yeah. So the safety net is not going
to stop you having an accident. It's just going to help you
financially in the accident. So you're saying that it might
make you. That's the Tulex spike theory,
that if you have bigger consequences, then you'll take
less risk. And that's the same as in
competitions. If they say that we're going to
do things to make it safer, then pilots will take more risks to
get back to the same level of risk that they were comfortable
with in both cases. So you compensate that way, but
it doesn't stop the accident happening.
It doesn't prevent the consequences of the accident.
It may prevent some of the financial consequences and
that's about it. So.
Yeah, I wouldn't worry about that too much.
And with reserve parachutes, I only only used it as an example,
but I saw a video probably 1520 years ago someone saying that if
you get into this much trouble and you have an accident, then
throwing the reserve gets you into this much trouble.
But if you accidentally deploy, you go from that much trouble
into this much trouble. Like it's still pretty serious
situation if you're throwing the reserve.
So in my case, so I thought a lot of the places I fly, if I
threw the reserve, I don't know where I'd end up.
Like on a glacier, on some Rocky Mountain or in a river.
It might be better to just not have one.
And if I'd not had one during the accident, I probably would
be completely fine. I just would have had a
concussion. So yeah, every, every time you
do a risk management thing, you have to re evaluate the risk
again. So you say, OK, there's a risk
so I'll get insurance, but then you've got to re evaluate the
risk again, OK, I'll have insurance, but that'll only stop
this and this. It won't stop that and that.
It'll still be, there'll be a lot of serious consequences
either way. But the other thing I say about
risk, because if you're worried about going to hospital, you
should probably go to 1 and have a look around and see all the
people there. And if you walk down the aisles,
there's a few people who are young males driving too fast,
had a car accident, motorbike accident, but in reality it's
mostly old people. So in the end, old age gets you
in. Some people are luckier than
others with genetics and inherited things.
They have their body getting old, but that's basically the
biggest core of death or hospitalisation is old age.
Yeah, in the end you've just got to.
For me, when I learnt paragliding, my instructor was
talking to his, but he's saying this guy, if he survives, he
might end up being pretty good because he's motivated to do new
things and do exciting things but also dangerous things.
But my philosophy was I'm trying to have as much as fun as I can
before I die. And if I die or if I become a
tetraplegic after one year of paragoning, then there's not a
lot of fun I can have in one year compared to 15 years.
So I'm going to try to manage the risk so I can stay alive,
not have an accident, and then I can have more fun over a longer
period of time rather than having too much fun in a short
period of time because I did something too silly.
What's Tetra you? You said the word tetraplexic.
What's that pledic? I'm not sure what I say.
OK, so paraplegic is the only word I thought you said Oh.
Paraplegic. Yeah, tetraplegic.
If you're paraplegic, it's more or less waist down and
tetraplegic. You don't have full use of your
arms. OK, that's a pretty sad state to
be then. Yeah, some people like they need
help to feed themselves and need help to go to the toilet.
They can't really do anything for themselves.
Me, I can't go up and down steps or in and out of narrow gaps,
and there's other things below your waist than the legs.
But I can still be pretty independent.
I'm paraplegic from the T12 level, which is the thoracic
vertebrae, the very bottom one, so the L1 which is the first
lumbar spine. It's basically waist level that
broke and my spine is fused 2 above and two below.
They call me complete or Asia A which is complete paraplegic so
I've got nothing but that's just when they do all the tests.
I do have some feeling in certain places my left leg is
better than my right. My feet themselves, I don't have
any feeling, but I've got quite a bit of feeling on my legs,
like skin touch and heat and cold in certain areas.
So yeah, it's a bit hit and miss.
But if you've got a high break, if you're like a tetraplegic,
then there's organs below the brake which don't work properly.
So for me it's sexual function, bladder, bowels and legs.
But higher up it could be problems regulating your body
temperature. Damn.
Also the spinal cord when the doctor taps you on your knee and
you kick. Your leg, Yeah, the reflex.
That's yeah. So a reflex is when you the
signal that your legs been kicked goes to your spine and
then your spine replies straight away to tell you to kick your
butt. Normally the signal goes to the
brain but if it goes to the spine it's faster but the brain
can still override it. Like you can concentrate on not
kicking your leg and then you'll stop it from kicking.
But the reflex reaction is your spinal cord replying.
So if you've got a higher brake then the lower part of your
spinal cord will do reflex and that can cause people to have
spasms. And because of my brake, it's at
the bottom of the spine. So I don't have any signals that
never, the signals never get to the spine at all.
So I don't have any spasms. They're called.
So some people, their legs will start shaking around.
For me, it's just everything's passive and nothing like that
happens. Yeah.
I'm a bit curious about test testester on Nick, because
please don't confuse this with libido by any means.
Just the usual, let's say the things that make you angry,
passionate, whatever. Whatever is the function of
Testester on does that, Do you still have those same kind of
drive for everything or did that take a hit?
Yeah, I don't think the feelings or emotions or that that kind of
thing has really changed that much.
I was just lucky generally that because I'm older people who
have spinal accidents, some people that have bad luck with
some kind of disease or whatever, or some kind of
accident that's not really from taking risks.
People can trip over a fence or something and get a spinal
injury and maybe they're not so fit.
I could take a lot of falls and not get much damage because I'm
more fit and used to taking falls.
But yeah, so generally the people who will have accidents
from doing silly things are young males, right?
And for them, it's a part of their life where they're wanting
to do lots of things. But for me, I'm older.
I've already taken years off work just to travel around the
world. I've done a lot of things.
And so I'm pretty happy with all the things that I've done.
And it's not like I've, there's been times in my life where I've
been thinking I've got to go out and I've got to do these things,
but then I've gone and done them.
So I'm happy that way. I'm a bit older, so I don't have
the like young guys driving fast cars.
I'm just happy cruising around. But I don't think it's because I
had a spinal injury that I'm happy cruising around relatively
slowly on the country roads instead of driving real fast.
I don't think that's because of my spinal injury.
I think it's just because I'm a bit more older and chilled out
and managed to do all those things.
And I've had 15 years of experiences paragliding, which
is a pretty good run. As a friend said, yeah, I think
that was answering your question.
OK, like there's so many other topics that I want to move on
to. But before we close on to this
one, first thoughts, Nick, when you were by yourself, when the
dust settled, let's say you're you're in the hospital, people
have given you the preliminary report and everything.
And then when you finally have a moment by yourself, how did the
thought process look like when you finally were able to
comprehend what just happened? So the first week in hospital, I
recorded a couple of videos. We're going to link it in the
description. So anybody who's very curious, I
would recommend go check out Nick's website channel.
The amount of information there is nothing but a gold mine.
Go on, please. Yeah.
It was interesting that I seemed to get more viewership after the
accident than all the pretty videos of me flying through the
mountains for the first week. I made those videos and you can
see that I was more or less OK, but the same as if you're really
tired because I've been through a lot.
It was hard to sleep physically. I was really bashed around in
the crash. It wasn't just a spinal injury.
My teeth had gone through my tongue.
I had stitches there. I had scratches all over my
face. I had something that connects to
the the heart nearly ripped out and I nearly died from that.
I had other internal damage, heavy physical falls, but we
only found out several days into it that they had me on all these
painkillers. And I'm like, I've never said
that I was in pain once. I've never complained about
being in pain once. What's happening?
Like, and I had the messages that I was sending before the
accident and it's like, I'm just talking normally.
It doesn't sound like I'm in pain.
What's the story? But I didn't realise the main
accident was actually after the helicopter arrived.
So yeah, my head was, it was hard to think straight and you
get all funny kinds of dreams and you're not really sure what
reality is when you're getting all these drugs.
I got off the drug straight away as soon as I found out I was on
them before. He's been trying to get off
drugs quickly and I haven't been on drugs since I left the
hospital after the rehab. But yeah, so.
But basically, after all the injuries, the internal injuries
had calmed down and I'd been off the drugs and then I'd been able
to sleep a bit better. Then I became a bit more back to
normal. And there was never any really
sudden psychological recovery or damage or anything like that.
I always knew it was dangerous activity.
I figured, Yep, OK, what could have happened finally happened.
And yeah, And when I made the video, about probably 5 months,
four or five months after the accident, I got everything that
I knew, basically the messages I'd sent on my phone, the
conversations I've had with other people, the video footage
that I had, the track logs. And I put everything I knew into
the video. And it wasn't really an
emotional thing for me. I was just thinking like, what
was there some particular risk that applied the day?
And I was like, yeah, it wasn't really anything in particular
that was risky about that day. I've done a lot more sillier
things than that. And it is what it is.
I would say in general, when you're flying in the mountains,
it often happens that you're close to terrain.
And if something happens when you're close to terrain, you
don't have much time to get the wing flying again.
And that's just what happened to me.
Yeah. I never had any regrets, really,
because I didn't know what to regret because I don't remember
the actual accident. And yeah, psychologically there
was not a big problem. But after that accident video,
it got really popular. Someone contacted me through
Instagram and they said the French shouldn't investigate
this, so contact this person and they'll look into it.
So I started emailing the BA, the investigation people in
France, and they investigate it. And a few months later I said
what's going on? And they didn't really want to
tell me. And they said we'll have to have
a meeting. And we finally organised to talk
about what happened because they didn't just send me the PDF,
they wanted to do a video conference about it.
Then I realized that the helicopter had blown me down the
hill and my partner was there and she was kind of, yeah,
obviously fairly emotionally affected by it.
But I kind of felt, oh, well, at least it wasn't as much my fault
as I thought. So I felt a little bit relieved
of the responsibility for it. So yeah, basically you're
talking about the psychological effects in, in, in terms of,
yes. So the accident, it was always
dangerous, always could have happened in terms of what can
you do about it? My mum's really good with her
way of thinking about that. She's a doctor and she came over
the first week of the accident. She was there.
I'm not sure how many days it took her to get there, but she
was basically just like in France.
Yeah. And she was like, what can I do?
How can we help things get a little bit better?
There was no real emotion from her.
It's just what can we practically do to make things a
little bit better in the future rather than thinking about the
past? Yeah.
I feel like this is a master class in anger management, the
way you dealt with even after getting the reality of the fault
of the pilot, which was unintentionally.
I believe this is where there's a huge communication gap that
rescue choppers are first of all, like double engine,
massively heavy, insane amounts of downwash from the rotors.
And then you come across a pilot who is lying motionless but
still connected. The amount of damage that you
can create by swatting around already injured pilot is insane.
And this is what makes me angry, man.
Like if somebody fucked up, like if that pilot fucked up, even if
it was unintentional, like at least make it public so other
pilots don't. Because I do clearly remember I
used to listen to Gavin a lot when I started.
I mean he was one of the inspiration before starting the
show. He mentioned very clearly that
there was a girl, I don't know which episode but where had a
crash called in the chopper, was unconscious, the chopper comes
in, blows her further away and she passes away from that.
The more we try to suppress such information, the more
susceptible we make the future generations to be facing the
same consequences without learning from it.
Even if it makes owning up your fuck ups.
That is the easiest way to describe it on an institutional
level. The easiest way is to just
swallow the heart pill and do it for the sake of tomorrow and not
for the sake of saving your ass today.
Yeah. So the organization made those
decisions for whatever reasons they made them for.
That's why I made the YouTube video.
And a few people commented on my YouTube video that we work with
the rescue helicopters in this country and we just saw your
video and we shared it with all our colleagues.
And so that was one reason for making the video is exactly what
you're talking about. Did you ever find it difficult
or what was your coping mechanism with anger?
Anger management, because I think a lot of us loved dwelling
in the past that fuck, I could have done this right?
Like, you know, I could have fixed this or how I can fix
future. But you, the way you're speaking
about it seems like you, you just, yeah, did not bother you
up to a point where you're life would be affected.
So how did you regulate your emotions and anger?
And what was your go to thing when you felt you were losing
the plot at times? Quite a lot of times where I
thought about things that I used to be able to do that I can't do
anymore. And it's pretty hard because
it's not so easy to forget that you're paralysed.
Like when you're moving around, you can't walk, you're in a
wheelchair. So you're kind of reminded of
that all the time, just through all your sensations basically,
and pushing the wheelchair around and when you're asleep
and it's hard to roll over, I've got to have all the plumbing
hooked up for the peeing and all that kind of thing.
So it's basically, it's in your face all the time.
You can't really forget about it.
One of the things where you can forget about it, I would say, is
gliding because you're using the hand instead of the feet, But
basically you're flying through the air.
You're not really using your feet much in the glider anyway.
You're just sitting down and you're just using them for the
rudder. And you do it a different way.
But basically you can feel just like a glider pilot before,
after the accident, but when you're going down the street,
you're pushing the wheelchair. It's reminding you all the time
that you're sitting down. But yeah, anger management, the
things that make me angry are the practical things, like,
yeah, I guess sometimes I'm sad. And all the other people taking
risks, like people doing wing tip touches on the glacier in
Pakistan, I'm just like that. I know these guys are good, but
the risks are completely different in Pakistan and
Europe. You're at much higher altitude
and there's no support. If you land, you don't have the
same kind of facilities that you do in Europe.
And why would you do that? What's the risk to benefit of
that wing tip touch or whatever? So I see people doing these
risky things and getting away with it.
And I'm like, I wonder if, but everyone takes a chance and some
people get lucky and some don't. And you just don't know how many
lives you're going to have. Yeah.
So some of the time I would get UPS, you know, or, or, you know,
miss not being able to do the things that I used to do.
But the other two major things were practical things.
Like the main problem for me is leaking urine because yeah, I
can do a transfer, like move myself from one place to
another, but it'll push everything out of my bladder.
So I try to keep my bladder empty all the time, but there's
always a little bit in there that'll leak out.
So having to deal with that can be quite annoying.
The most annoying thing is when you get out of the shower and
then you just leak a little bit and you're like, I just had a
shower or I've had a before. With the bowels it's even worse,
but luckily much rarer. But yeah, if you get diarrhea,
there's not much you can do, and it's pretty hard to clean
yourself up when you can't stand up.
The other annoying thing is the bureaucracy.
So I had to wait for 9 or 10 months in Spain to get my
medical license to fly gliders solo, and the club there was
amazing. They helped me through it.
Spain or France? Yeah, I was doing the flying in
France, but I lived for a while in Spain and we decided to get
it there and they had a really good club.
I've still been actually flying there yet, but it's normally
quite a hassle to get you medical.
You got to get all the tests done, but it's only a few hours.
But when you disable, they make you do basically all you have to
do is get in and out of a glider in front of some bureaucrat from
Madrid. But the process of getting to
that point takes nine months of jumping hoops and all this
nonsense, bureaucratic nonsense. So that was annoying and at the
same time I was trying to get my driving license.
I gave up on Spain because the bureaucracy there is completely
dysfunctional. I came back to Australia and did
it, but there was quite tricky. I had to find the right people,
get it sorted. You can get a license, but that
doesn't mean you can drive. You're supposed to pay several
$1000 to get a car modified for the hang controls, even though
you can buy something off eBay for a couple of 100 bucks to do
the same thing. Yeah, you can get angry about
all that bureaucracy or you can just ignore it and keep going on
with your life. So yeah, I would say there was
three things like missing what you can't do, dealing with all
the practical problems and then dealing with the bureaucracy
dramas. The other problem I had when I
came to Australia where I spent all my working life, I wanted to
join the national disability like where you get funding and
now I have 10s of thousands of dollars of funding but I spend
less than 5% of what I can because I just don't need to buy
useless things. But all I needed was a cushion
and these are $1000 cushions to stop me getting skin damage on
my bum. And I ended up having to spend a
week lying on my belly in the bed just to try the skin to
heal. This injury can keep coming back
a lot easier than if I'd never damaged it in the first place.
And I'm using these questions all the time just in case.
That's annoying that, that bureaucracy.
I, I anticipated that it'll take a few months and I got ready
ahead of time. But then they, they say, oh, we
have to, we have to apply again because you, your Centrelink
doesn't address doesn't match up with something else in mind.
What's haven't you Centrelink in over a decade?
What's, who cares anyway? It got sorted.
But yeah, it that's a frustrating thing when
something, if they can't fix your spinal injury, that's fine.
Like medical, there's a limitation to what we can do
physically. But if it's just a bureaucracy
thing, then you can get upset. But since Palestine has been
going on for two years, I feel like I'm very lucky compared to
some. And it's like that in the spinal
ward as well. Other people who had worse luck
than you, they didn't get 15 years of amazing adventures.
So yeah, it's just the way it goes.
Tell me a little bit about insurance, Nick, because I think
a lot of pilots who fly there just click on the pay button and
forget about it and leave or trust the federation or like
other people who are getting paid to fix if it needs to be
activated. But what happens with the
insurance? What's the bureaucracy behind
insurance? How does it work?
I'm not really an expert on this subject.
It was a massive hassle trying to get insurance, especially for
the X Alps. It's hard enough to ensure
paragliding as it is. As soon as insurance companies
find out about paragliding, they'll put it in there.
We don't cover this category. And if you have a competition,
then like anything that covers paragliding, it probably doesn't
want to cover paragliding competitions as well.
So it's even harder to find someone.
Like they have to make money and it's expensive to take care of
people when they have these accidents.
Yeah, I would like to talk about New Zealand because, yeah,
basically I've been working and living in Australia for most of
my adult life. We just expected we would go
back there and I'd do the rehabilitation, but their spinal
ward was basically full. I'd be waiting for months.
And the guy said you've got a New Zealand passport, why don't
you just go there? And just because they have the
passport, even though I wasn't living there, they took me in
and they gave me rehab, they gave me a wheelchair, they gave
me everything. Yeah, thanks to the New Zealand
taxpayer. I have to say I love the New
Zealand system because instead of fighting with accountants and
lawyers and insurance and bureaucracy, they just pay for
doctors and nurses. Admittedly they don't pay as
much in Australia. Like there's heaps of nurses
moving to AUS for better money. But yeah, they treat anyone that
has an accident and you can be a visitor as well.
And yeah, I don't have heaps of parallels coming to New Zealand
and having accidents to maybe make New Zealand reconsider
that. But yeah, it is great that you
can not spend so much of your life worrying about this stuff
in a country like this. And unfortunately not many other
countries around the world do it like that.
So yeah, it's something that probably the best way to solve
it is as a group. I know Gavin Mcclurg's done a
bit of work trying to figure out the different options and yeah,
I think basically talk with. Your paragarding buddies took
with the association to try to figure out something as a group.
Don't ask me because it's because I didn't have the best
results. I was wondering the paperwork
behind activating it or if there's any cash kickback from
insurance. Like does insurance cover you
with money as well? Do they give you a lump sum in
such cases? Or is it more or less to ensure
that you are able to eventually reach back home without worrying
about money on the way? Oh, there's lots of different
paths to insurance, so the main one is whether you're covered at
all, whether there's an exemption.
It may or may not include bringing you to the hospital, it
may or may not include the medical care, it may or may not
include sending you home. There's all these different
things to think about. But in my case, once I got home,
I would be covered for free in Australia.
It would have just taken a lot longer to get treated and New
Zealand just took me in straight away and I'm very thankful for
that. So yeah, just lucky to have that
passport. Let's talk a little bit about
flying. You're back to chasing it.
Yeah, more fun matter. You can glide faster, you can
glide further, and you're not facing any cold wind on your
face. What's the comparison feel like,
man? From paragliding to sailplanes
as a former paraglider pilot. The difference is, for me,
paragliding is about independence, freedom and
adventure, and gliding is about flying.
Flying a glider is a much better way to fly because you've got
much better performance, you can fly much further, you can
explore a lot more places and do a lot more things, and you can
get back. But the downside of gliding is
that you can't land on a mountain in the middle of
nowhere. You can't take off from a
mountain in the middle of nowhere.
You can't take a glider and check it into your luggage and
turn up in another country and go flying there.
It's not so flexible that way. So.
Yeah. But in terms of flying, yeah.
For a start, you're in a canopy, so it's not windy, it's not
cold, it's in the sun and out of the wind.
And the dynamics like being able to pull up and put the nose down
and go faster, the performances means you have so many more
chances to find lift than you do with a paraglider where you can
just cross a valley and then you've got to start again.
And because you've got so many chances, you don't need to
dribble around and just survive and scratch around and weak lift
just to stay in the air. You can just power on through
and only stop for the best climbs.
Or sometimes you can just not even turn at all if you're
following. Like once I I got low about 80
kilometers from home and there was some big storm clouds
developing. I thought maybe I shouldn't keep
finishing this big triangle that I had planned then I'll just
start going home now. So after I got my low, which I
wasn't that worried about finding because there was a
cloud shadow and I knew there'd be a climb there somewhere.
You can glide so far before you. Yeah, it was easy to find a
climb. And once I got to cloud based, I
flew about 80 KS back home, staying at cloud base and not
turning because I was just following lifty lines along
clouds. So yeah, it really is a lot
better flying compared to yeah, you have to be a lot more candy
and selective. If you look at all the
paragliding flights in Europe, which is really the best place
to fly in the world with the weather, the mountains and
infrastructure, most of the flights that cross country
pilots are doing are very carefully planned to follow the
easiest or the best terrain to get them to fly a big distance
that day. There's some places where it's
just too difficult across the valley or like they're following
the sunny faces in the morning, that they've planned the whole
thing to make it as easy as possible for them.
And you kind of have to because otherwise you just can't do it.
But with gliding, yeah, it's a different story.
The thrill. I completely understand that
you're different. Cockpits are like different
sensations. But do you?
Is it more or less the same, or is it different because you're
sitting in a very protected structure?
I don't know what the exact statistics are.
I think gliding has fewer accidents, but a higher
percentage of the accidents are fatality.
Because paragliding is slow speeds.
You're probably just going to have a crash and walk away or
not walk away. So because of the slowest speeds
in paragliding, there's a lot of accidents where you don't die.
They're both quite dangerous sports and a lot of it does come
down to your attitude and the levels of risks that you take.
But in terms of the sensation where you're not really thinking
about risk, you're just thinking about how fun it is.
I really love cranking it in a thermal in a glider.
You really bank it over tight. And I've taken a paraglider and
she was surprised that how steeply you do turn and how
tight you do turn, it's just a lot more that you can do with
it. Like paraglider in the
competitions, people are mashing full speed bar because you can
go as fast as you like and it's still not that fast.
But yeah, I hate pushing the bar.
It's uncomfortable, it gets annoying, but in the glory you
just lean on the stick and you would never go as up to V&E like
the Max speed. You just go as fast as it makes
sense to in those cross country conditions.
I'd say it's a great feeling and a lot of the time I fly just
because of the beauty of what's around me and you get to see a
lot of things gliding. So yeah, I guess with the
gliders you don't hear the birds singing or the sound of the
waterfalls when you fly past, but it's still a great feeling.
I'd say before before the accident I would like doing both
the independence and adventure for the paragliding, but the
flying for gliding. So what I was going to say is
that more or less your life has gifted you a more immersive or
more rewarding form of aviation if you look at it that way.
A lot of people in the gliding club that I fly with in France
also paraglide as well, but they'll tend to do hike and fly
more than a nine hour cross country flight.
If it's a big cross Country Day, they'll probably just go
gliding. A lot of paragliders get too
carried away with the distancing when you're flying the slowest
aircraft. I have been like that myself.
I love to do long flights and use the whole day.
That's what I like about the X helps is you're trying to get
the most that you can out of the day.
And I didn't really like conventional competition so much
because you're sitting on the hill and you're waiting for
briefings and then you're flying a few hours, but there's so many
other hours you could fly that you don't so.
Yeah, Nick, when a person like you who is so willing to share
comes on the show, I often lose my plot because there are so
many things we can talk about. But there is a time limit and I
believe we are in a 12 hour time difference.
It's 10:30 in the morning in Oslo, but I would suppose you
would get drowsy soon enough if you don't call it a day.
OK, before we wrap this up, I really want to talk about
Corioid because that has been a bit of a pain point and I
believe we as a community are failing to throw enough light or
even discuss it enough. Your harness, I mean exhalps or
just that side of flying is more or less lightweight to me.
I don't know how or when. OK, this is where I would like
to tell our listeners, viewers, a bit of a story.
When I was in my first like new beginners course, I had my
instructor telling me to do a beeline install.
I don't know if it was stupid, but that was the norm of that
instructor to every single student to make them do beeline
installs. Not crazy, not too deep, just
feel how it feels to pull the beelines, which I think was kind
of cool. And I was like, you know what, I
want to do a helico. I had no idea what a helico was.
And this was like 5th or 6th flight.
And I was like, that looks cool. And if you are pushing me to
beeline, then I want to get pushed further.
So tell me how to do a helico. And he was like fuck off, this
is not happening. And I was like, why?
Tell me, explain it to me that why can't I do helico when I'm
comfortable doing wing overs on my 5th or 6th flight or I'm
unable to do beeline on my 7th or 8th or whatever it is.
And he said something later on which stuck with me, which was
like, what's the point of living a life by chasing excitement of
wing overs but having a very real risk of just lying around
in bed and being fed by tubes because you were stupid in one
instance. And it was shocking to hear that
because my psyche was that fuck, I'm going to do Helicos, I'm
going to do wing overs. It's going to be crazy exciting.
And then this guy is dude, that is one side of the reality if
you do everything right and if life is kind enough to you.
But the other reality is that you get fed by tubes.
And it shook me so hard deep inside that every single time,
next time I went to make a decision which was going to have
an impact on my safety, that thing like came back in my head
and said that, hey, consider this before you decide that.
So a lot of times when I've been considering chasing leaside
thermals or pushing full or like pushing the comfort zone or even
picking up equipment for that matter, it was like, buddy, the
worst is that the best is this now based on how you want to
decide? Same mentality came while
choosing A harness because I was in GTOI.
Started my career in GTO Lite. Yeah I only used chair hardness
for the school time. Went to a pod straight up after
the 1st 10:15 flights and I deployed and ended up in a
reserve under a tree. During that time when I was
hanging, life was hard. The straps were digging into my
thighs and they were cutting off the blood circulation.
I quickly realized that if I don't stop this the blood is
going to pump down and I might pass out or something worse
happens if I'm stuck here for God knows how long.
Did not have a cut knife or whatever but eventually I
managed to fix it. But The thing is as soon as I
was walking away I was like you are buying a XR7.
I don't care how difficult it is to walk around with it, but
hands down it has the best protection.
So at least fix things you can with money and then let your
skills, life, destiny takes its own course.
A month ago I did a very informational episode on how to
pick up your harness with another pilot.
It. It has been received very well
where we are talking about how back protection is not even
considered a big part of the ecosystem anymore, whereas the
last generation of harness back protector was everything.
So when it comes to be deciding or making decisions, is there a
better way to make them because you have imagined the worst
possible outcome around it? Or is ignorance is a bliss
because destiny will takes its own course any which ways?
Yeah, so I was taught there were two things that we could never
do when we were learning. One is walk around with your
harness without all the buckles done up because it's either
completely on or completely off because people have fallen to
the death because they forgot to do their harness buckles up.
And the other one was that we always had to be upright out of
the harness for a good time after we launched and a good
time before we landed. So if you came back to the
ground, you would be on your feet.
That was the most important thing for me.
Some back protectors are better than others, sure, or whatever.
But there's basically just two factors.
One is the distance and the other one is the time.
As long as you can use that full distance, then that's how much
protection you have. If you have your legs, you have
about a metre, A metre to slow it down.
But if you have a back protector that's 30 centimetres, then
you've got 30 centimetres instead of a metre.
If you've got a small one, it doesn't matter what it's made
of, the most it can do is slow things down in that distance.
Now with keroid ones, maybe they weren't compressing the whole
way, so they were only going a little way and they weren't
getting that resistance. So that's the physics of it, I
think. And even the day before the
accident in the footage, I was talking about my friend's
landing. Good that he's got his feet out
because that was always on my mind and that was the most
important thing was your landing technique rather than
protection. And I have flown with a harness
that was just like a nappy harness before.
And it's like we were talking about before with the telex bike
and that if you don't have protection that you'll fly more
safely. But when I wake up in hospital
and I've broken my back, I'm like, OK, maybe I got that
wrong. I thought I would have been good
at landing my feet, but here I am with spinal injury.
But afterwards when I found out what happened, I'm like OK or
even before I found out what happened, I assumed there must
have been multiple falls, I must have hit the ground hard.
But I would have landed on my feet the first time and then
maybe I got knocked out and crashed on my leg, whatever.
But I found out what actually happened.
I'm not really sure if I'd be better off with different back
protection because I think that if I landed on my feet at 1m and
it compresses, and I say that, that's always going to be better
than half a meter of the best possible back protection in the
world because you just got more distance to have the physical
deceleration. But if I was blowing 50 meters
down and I was hitting rocks on the way, then probably even if I
had my feet out, I could still get the spinal damage right
because you can only decelerate so much in 1m and then you're
still going to be cracked further on.
It could be that a better harness would have saved me, but
I'm not sure how I survived anyway.
So yeah, definitely. It's always good to have safer
things if everything else is equal for me, yeah.
I don't know. Other people have studied it
more than I have. It was definitely something that
I don't really regret because I know that I had a good attitude
towards always landing on my feet.
And yeah, I think that's the most important thing.
I think what else can help as well.
What I wanted to highlight was in the harness episode my guest
Eros Jolt. Super interesting guy.
He mentions jerk rating and he says that Courier, as you
mentioned, the smaller protection you have, the smaller
area you have to travel. So the jerk rating in Courier is
a lot lower than in any other form of protection.
Has it ever come to you that maybe Courier is dangerous or
something or it shouldn't be a part of the system?
Or is it like, Nah man, it is what it is, I think.
There's a lot of factors in the accident.
Maybe the wing I was flying, maybe I should have flown a bit
bigger wing. I'd plan it for over a month and
I was quite happy with it. But there could be a lot of
different things that improve. But I think the main factor in
my accident was just the accident which unfortunately
helicopter staff didn't notice. The bright yellow parachute on
the ground. There's always things you can
improve and probably the harness is a fairly significant one
being most on my mind. I wanted to get your thoughts
because I believe we are standing at the crossroads in
the industry where serious decisions might be taken in this
regard, especially in the pilots union group that has been
formed. So yeah, every bit of opinion
helps. But what do you mean that 5
pilot crew did not notice there was a parachute lying around?
How is that possible when you're flying that close to the terrain
in that big of a machine? Well, to start with, the flew
past to see how it was going. Then they dropped off one
person. This is all in the video that I
did about it. But yeah, the first person was
holding my glider to make sure it didn't get blown by the
chopper, but somehow they didn't see this parachute.
There's a photo hikers took from half a kilometer away where you
can see this big bright yellow dot in the middle of the grass.
So yeah, I don't know how they didn't manage it.
Apparently they didn't have radio communications properly,
so maybe? If someone saw it, they wouldn't
be able to tell the others, but yeah, that it was when they came
back to get me that it happened. But anyway, watch the video for
that. But yeah, as I said, it's a
mistake and it's one that's a bit surprising and maybe we
should talk about or they should at least share it with the other
rescue pilots and just make sure that kind of thing doesn't
happen again. Because I did hear of someone
else that crashed maybe through the reserve or something.
Ended up on the top of a roof in pretty bad condition, but the
helicopter came and blew them off the roof and finished them
off kind of thing. And you said you'd heard of one
as well, and I know there's been others.
So yeah, it's like insurance. So you can't just get the rescue
helicopter and assume everything's going to be OK.
Every time you add something to manage the risk, you've got to
reassess the risks again from scratch because you could be
introducing new risks. Yeah.
OK, I want to close, but before this I want to share one thing
because they came back to the risk topic.
Back in India when I was flying, I was just about to upgrade my E
and A to E&B and I did actually. I was my 90 hour pilot.
I was flying the front Ridge, fairly turbulent and I had just
come in for the season, upgraded my wing, super excited, had
three or 45 flights to it. Did not have a reserve yet
because it was in transit, It was coming.
So I was flying without a reserve in beer billing without
telling anyone because I felt it was within my comfort zone.
But of course I thought I was mitigating risk enough.
Then I casually mentioned it to my mentor instructor and I was
like I don't have a reserve and I was like are you fucking
stupid? That is nothing but madness.
So beg, borrow, steal, do whatever but don't take another
flight without reserve. Anyways, asked a friend, got his
reserve, went out chasing same distance and everything that I
had. Man, believe it or not, two days
later after borrowing, I deployed.
Thankfully, that is the only time I have deployed until now
in my flying career. But it was like the first four.
It could have been fluke, it could have been luck, I'm not
going to lie. But the first four days my risk
perception was very different from the risk perception that I
had when I had a reserve in my harness.
I think this is a dilemma everybody has to answer for
themselves. Do they fare well with more
support around them or do they perform better when they are by
themselves? Because right now chopper
rescues are giving me a bit of an anxiety man.
It's like yeah if you're conscious and able to do
something then it is a lifeline but if not then it is almost
like a sure shot risky thing because no chopper.
Majority of the chopper pilots don't know how a paraglider
works or are at least bothered in finding out.
Fuck offs like these are going to remain covered up so the
organization as a whole saves its face.
So hush thing then. Maybe it's better to only
activate it when the pilot is conscious.
But anyways, I think people get the point.
A lot of aviation is good like that with reporting accidents,
but I guess paragliding it's less so in terms of reserve
uses. Deployed twice.
Once it was overwatered during SRV, and based on looking at the
timing and the height, I think if I hadn't deployed it would
have been equivalent to jumping off something 11 meters high.
So onto water. I probably would have been fine
if I hadn't had the reserve because I ended up wrapped in
the wing and it was going on this down after me.
But yeah, it was good to have it then I guess.
But I probably would have been fine without it because it was
over water. And the other time I deployed
it, I think if I didn't have the reserve with me, I had a big
line over, I would have just gone to land with the line over
and I probably would have been OK.
And the way it worked out, I was super lucky and it was a great
experience. But yeah, in 15 years, they're
the only times I used it. And apart from the third time
where I just, it got me in more trouble.
It depends what you're doing. It depends what you're saving
yourself from. A lot of the reason you would
use it is if you had a mid air. Yeah, paragliding.
Your wing is collapsible and there's a chance that you'll
throw it because you've got a wing collapse or whatever, or a
Corvette. But if you have a Corvette, you
can probably clear it if you're high.
And if you're not high, you might not have enough time to
throw the reserve. So it's still marginal.
Yeah, I mean, they are good, but I think it is debatable and it's
probably something, I mean, I guess you could do a whole
podcast just on that, but you probably better interview people
other than me because I've only had a few experiences in my 15
years of flying. Oh, geez, Nick, that's so well
summarized, man. Yeah, before I let you go, I
often wonder about this question.
A lot of times that if people knew, and this is like me
included, if eventually life was unfolded in front of you before
you started to or before you started it and said that, hey,
this is how things are going to plan out.
This is what you're going to do at this stage in your life.
If you knew that next 15 years of your flying career are going
to be like this, looking back at it, would you go back and do it
all over again or would you try to make any amends on the way?
Like in terms of did I get good value out of my accident with 15
years of flying? Yeah, I think it's pretty good.
Like I, I could have had an accident without those that
experience. I would have had been less
likely to have an accident if I didn't do the 15 years of
flying. But I'm thinking a good, good
bang for buck if there's specific things I would do
differently to reduce the amounts of risks.
I would say that overall I'm pretty happy because we didn't
really talk about actually I wrote a book after my accident.
I thought I've got a lot less excuses to not write a book now.
I've got a lot of adventures that we didn't talk about in
this podcast, travelling all over the world, flying through
remote areas, which some places maybe no one has flown before.
But that was super rewarding and it was definitely the best tool
for the job in terms of what you can do with that.
They can bring it with you on a plane and a bus, hitchhike, you
can really get around. And yeah, I think I got pretty,
pretty good bang for buck for what I did with it.
And considering all the things I did, I think it was relatively
low risk to be able to do that much stuff.
It it is a risky sport. But in terms of what I managed
to do with it, I did OK. Yeah.
Thanks for mentioning your book man.
I I completely slipped my mind when we were doing it.
But this allows me to restart one of my traditions on the show
where I used to ask my guests to share their one best or one
memory from their flying carrier.
Could be best, could be worse, or.
Whatever. There's not really a list of
best experiences. There's a lot of different ones,
but I'll just list the one that came to my mind.
Right now. I'm in Randfly, where we've been
here since July. We've started a hostile here and
it's in what I call rabbit country.
It's away from the Southern Alps to the east, so it's dry and
it's tussock and grass and you have sheep here and maybe a few
cows, but mostly sheep. When I came to fly in New
Zealand, I would normally stay away from this area.
I would go. I would be as close to the main
divide where all the glaciers and rainforests, Bush, beach,
forest is, and I wouldn't come out this way very often.
But one day it was quite windy and ended up doing a down window
like the usual Australian style where you fly with the wind.
So I did the closest I've come to flatland flying for parts of
it anyway, and I flew past this area and yeah, whenever I drive
from here to the East Coast, we go past the place where I landed
by the road and hitched back out.
So, yeah, that was cool flight. It started in the mountains,
going downwind, getting out of the mountains, but got a low
save at the neck between lakes. And then after that it was just
cruising along and I thought I might even have a chance of
making the East Coast and probably one or two more
thermals I would have. But of course the sea breeze got
me in the end. But that meant that I was flying
over the tops of the clouds as they were pouring over the the
Kakanois. Yeah.
I mean, it's just nice to do something different.
A lot of people in New Zealand, there's only a few pilots here,
but they've been trying to break the 200 K triangle.
And I was trying to do that myself.
But one thing I really like about the way that I did it is I
was always be trying a different triangle.
I wouldn't be trying the same route over and over.
And yeah, that's something special about paragliding.
You don't have to land back at the airfield the whole time or
you don't start. It's not like gliding where you
start and finish at the same place, but you can do different
things every time. So yeah, that was just one that
came to mind because it kind of ties in with where I am right
now. What's the book all about and
where can people get their hands on?
It it's basically about 15 years of flying adventures.
There's 15 chapters. It's not exactly year for year.
Each chapter has a different theme and it's supposed to be
written so it's not just for paragliding people but anyone
who's interested in adventure stories.
I'll try to stay away from the jargon and go through the
amazing experiences I've had over that 15 years.
It's called lessons from the sky.
I guess we can have a link. It's a tricky 1 to find, I've
only seen one version of it. I think it's on Amazon
somewhere. Nah, I think I'm going to look
it up and bring it out to people.
But yeah, man, I'm going to figure out a more structured
show on meteorology and bring you back to people as well,
because I think that is such an amazing knowledge.
Did you have some history with meteorology or what was your
background in that regard? It did a course in 2016, ten
month course with the Australian government and forecasted for
them for several years. And yeah, I would say probably a
lot of the stuff from the meteorology course I already
knew, but maybe you saw it from a different angle or got a bit
more maths behind it. There's a few new things that
are thought of flying experiences that I've had in the
past, and I understand what that was now, a few quirky things
that I learned out of it. It's an amazing job to be able
to look at the weather, look out the window, see all the
satellite imagery and all the data that we have coming in, and
then talk to people about what the weather features are and
what's happening. Aviation forecasting was more
about the next six hours and the next several days.
So it means you're doing a lot more observations rather than
weather models. Yeah, a week out.
Yeah. So I've done that for a few
years. I could still go back and do it.
I'd like to do it, but it mean I have to move back to Australia,
which is nice. But yeah, it's good being in New
Zealand too. I think hostel life is kind of
cool man because I had a hostel back in New Delhi before I moved
to. Oslo and OK down.
It was so much fun meeting new people and exchanging new
stories. Yeah, yeah.
It's pretty quiet out here, but it's just starting to be a bit
busier now. Basically you're on Hostel
World, booking like all of those segregators and then figuring.
Out, yeah, mostly booking.com and we have Airbnb, I guess.
I think we might be halfway through the hostel world
process, I'm not sure. It's a pain in the ass now.
I know hostel world is super slow compared to booking and
onboarding. Yeah, jeez, we're bringing back
most casualties from us. It can millionise that stuff
from a user perspective and she's not really sure if the
hostel were the ones with Raspberry.
It's more. Money, my man, regardless of
whatever it is. Yeah, but I can probably find
you if they want to, can't they? But.
Yeah, I think checking out your hostel gives me a reason to come
to that side of the world one day.
So I'm going to stay tuned for that, and the viewers can stay
tuned for the awesomeness that we have planned for them in the
coming weeks, including your metrology episode, which we will
get to discussing on the emails as soon as we stop recording.
But for now, Nick, it has been an absolute honor, man, I kid
you not. I have been wanting to get you
on the show for more than a year.
Like that's how long I've procrastinated over it.
Can you believe it? But finally glad to get it done
and can't wait for the next time.
Thanks very much for the interview.